genius brain fars this podcast is
brought to you by cook Unity you guys
already know it' be expensive exploring
that local food seeing my little Foodies
but guess what with cook Unity they are
the first chef to use service delivering
locally sourced meals from awardwinning
chefs right to your door every week and
is cheaper than other delivery options
all you have to do is go to cook
unity.com genius or enter code genius
before check out for 50% off your first
week and that my friends is a steal of a
deal and unlike other meal services cook
Unity is a chef Collective bringing EX
exciting culinary Talent straight to
your table so you already know that
meals are going to be banging just like
the salmon that I had super flavorful
super delicious and the calories were on
it so guess what I knew how much I was
eating so guess what my friends all you
got to do is go to cook unity.com genius
or enter code genius before checkout for
50% off your first week that's 50% off
your first week by using Code genius or
going to cookunity tocom genius genius
Bri and listeners this podcast is
brought to you by fume cold turkey may
be great on sandwiches but there's a
better way way to break your habits and
we're talking about doing it with fume
my friends they look at the problem in a
different way because not everything in
a bad habit is wrong so instead of
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bed from the habit and
that's the way to do it you got to use
the fume it's an awardwinning flavored
air device fume uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavor start the year off right with the
good habit by going to trif
fum.fi
listeners of the show 10% off when they
use my co genius to help make starting
the good habit that much easier start
the goodh Habit at tri.com genius to
save 10% off the journey pack today um
but yeah some of the outlandish things
that he said like you keep saying you
cannot Overlook come on Prince talk
coming to him for advice on cars women
and fashion in what
world is Prince coming to you for
[__] advice on women and fashion bro
like no Purple Rain I wrote
that I wrote that yeah in
54321 what is what you hyping yourself
up right now my titties are s 54321
what's up everybody Welcome to the
genius brain podcast where we talk about
current news a month late so or later or
way later people always want me to do
topics like during but that it's like I
don't want to jump on topics without
knowing knowing about it
and so there's a couple things that
people wanted us to talk about right
number one we'll talk about the Cat
Williams thing that happened right now
every time Cat
Williams comes out from wherever the
[__] he's coming out from this's always
stirring [__] up this fool is a
professional [__] talker and one of my
favorite [__] talkers he's hilarious
he's hilarious he's so [__] funny and
just like the way he delivers his lines
it makes me laugh so hard I mean cuz
comedians are generally pretty quick
witted but like his sarcasm and and and
his delivery and his timing it's just
impeccable well here's the thing right
so if you guys don't know shanon sharp
love I love shanon sharp too he's goofy
as [__] skip skip come on skip come on
SK what are you saying skip you
know Skip come on skip oh Lord Jesus I
love him Southern dude
hilarious now has his own podcast called
Club sh sh
he's had Steve Harvey he's had Cedric
the
Entertainer and now he has Cat Williams
on so I guess Cat Williams he says that
he's heard these podcasts and they're
all telling lies so he is here to set
the record for he chose violence and he
chose pure [__] violence and the
things that he said was [__] nuts to
me right here's the thing about C before
we start getting into the specifics one
of the things that makes me laugh about
Cat Williams the most is he's the only
person I know that has numbers and
statistics ready to go like that I know
that you can't verify right at all yeah
favorite one yeah I read about 3,000
books a year books a year logistically
not even possible 3,000 books a [__]
year depending like eight and a half
books a day yeah I did the math too yeah
how would you do 3,000 and like people
always just kind of glaze over these
things right because they're calling him
the truth teller like oh this guy's
speaking facts he said he read 3,000
books a day and non-fictional but there
was like so many things that was I mean
when he's talking about the Illuminati
with with him and ludicrous yeah
sometimes you want to be like for real
well here's the thing I I think it's
like that fine line between is he
serious or is this a shtick is this a
set you know that he's doing it's kind
of to me I think it's half truth h exact
it's like painting a picture of your
mind of what's happening but then if he
painted it in the way of like a secret
society we can we can conjure it up in
exactly like the way he speaks about
things right you could tell that there's
something is rooted in truth here but
he's definitely fabricating exing
is 3,000 books a year and did he say
like he went to college at like 13 or
something oh I forgot what the stat was
for him running like a dash or whatever
the [__] it four point like
it was something fter than you or
something sh sh was like all right yeah
come on he he didn't even no he when he
talked about running that the the 40
yards he like Shannon sharp didn't even
like like have a reaction really just
went past it like it's so ridiculous so
that's what I'm saying like I feel like
it's it's kind of understood that it's a
bit you know and like you said it's lot
some of the stuff is rooted in the truth
but it's like yeah there are going to be
moments where it's so outlandish that
it's like if it goes over your head that
this is not truth you know the problem
with people too online is that they only
want to focus on the stuff that they
care about but they kind of let all the
other stuff pass like you can't say he's
a truth teller when he just said he read
3,000 books a year so when somebody lies
like that they go whatever but what
about this no no no you can't say
whatever you have to still Focus context
matters context matters this right here
is in context to who he is as a person
that he could say
he read 7,000 books a year with a
straight [__] face like it's not a
joke like he can like if he maybe said
the wrong number right not thousand but
if he said 3 book I could believe that
instantly easy to believe you know okay
but then 3,000 why well what's also most
ridiculous about that claim is that he
said between the ages of s and
12 a kid yeah were ay old child picture
books are technically books but even
still how do you have that many books he
said non-fictional though he said they
were straight up books as he keeps
rubbing his [__] legs throughout the
whole interview no you know what like
before we get into the actual topics you
know what was hilarious about that
interview I don't know if you guys
caught this the whole time cat was
sitting on this tiny part of the couch
you know the part that sticks out on
yeah right he's so tiny that he fit in
that little little spot and he was
sitting there the whole time like on the
very edge and I was like that looks so
uncomfortable it's like a hammy rest
usually was so [__] weird like I
don't even know why people don't even
pick up on this like if he rubbed his
thighs anymore a [__] Genie would
have popped out of hisap like he was
just and you know what the [__] he has
these weird manner well he'll talk and
then when he's making a point he'll
stare right into the camera know you
that he goes I don't know sir but if you
look at the facts like cat who the [__]
are you looking at right now dude or or
or he'll give Shannon the you know the
little and it's just the random
statistics that always makes me laugh
who has these specific numbers in their
head locked like you could ask me
anything right it's like well how many
zoos have you been to it's like well
I've p 82 deers 46 Tigers 13 marsupial
and none of them were named Oprah he
looks right into the camera he had very
exact numbers such things like I don't
know anybody who has specific numbers
like that it's like well he's a genius
well it's kind of like the thing where
look there is actual video receipts
though for some of
the but then people are lumping in all
the other things as full truth yeah he's
telling certain things that are true and
certain things that are not one of the
things that everybody came forward are
all these like comics when they were
younger yeah they corroborated the story
where a random person would come up and
they would just give him like $10,000
$55,000 $3,000 and was all from Cat
Williams right so Cat Williams would go
to these like shows and he would see
like an upand cominging comic that he
thought was [__] dope yeah and he
sees that they're struggling he would
give it to some random girl say hey make
sure that you give this money to this
comic and they would just get this
random envelope and they don't know who
it's from but they would figure out
through the great find that it was from
Cat Williams yeah I mean there was yeah
there was definitely uh stories like
that coming out I remember one
particular comic uh he said that he was
supposed to open for cat and he was
super excited about it cuz he was like a
big fan of cat
but it turned out that cat wasn't going
to be showing up to see a set and he
felt like it was one of the best sets he
had ever done and then he he finished
got off and then he's like uh walking to
the back and in the hallway a man comes
out of the shadows and it's Cat Williams
and he's and he said cat like dapped him
up said great job young man and he gave
him like five times the pay that he was
supposed to get that's crazy yeah and he
and and Cat just basically said that was
incredible like I really enjoyed your
Set uh the rapper booy oh yeah he came
out how after he got out of prison like
he was just dead broke yeah and then
same thing one of cat's women had a
rolled up sock and it was
$115,000 to get him back on his feet
that's [__] crazy dude so there are
like real things which by the way you
got to understand that's pretty [__]
weird too yeah you I mean it is he had
to say that because Kevin Hart went on
The Breakfast Club to say Cat Williams
never brought any comedian up yeah yeah
he so he had to refute that obiously
right well the thing is too though like
he cat's not the one telling all these
stories about like how he treated these
up and coming comedians right he
wouldn't know that either yeah he he
never publicized that it's them coming
to his defense and saying like yo cat
actually did this for me right yeah I
mean he kind of it's interesting because
he's calling Kevin Hart an industry
plant right and he's and the the one of
the sections that kind of didn't make
sense but I maybe was trying to
understand what he was saying he was
like when have you ever seen a soldout
Kevin Hart show I've been two Kevin har
shows before he blew up sold out so I
don't know what the [__] he's talking
about I I think I think he's talking
about when Kevin Hart was coming up no
I'm talking about I knew of Kevin Hart
when he was coming up and he had these
small shows I went to them like mid
2000s like this is before he blew up I
went I was a huge still am a huge Kevin
terrible
movies the lift the worst one of the
worst movies I've ever seen in my
[__] life but that's I think that's
what Cat Williams is talking about
though Kevin Hart will say yes to
everything yeah that's why he's a
industry whatever whether a plant or an
Illuminati but then yes the big bosses
love Kevin har 100 he says yes to
everything but then you know him saying
that nobody there's no sold out Kevin
Hart shows before he was known that's
not [__] true because I guess if he's
talking about early on his career of
course not but then once he gets his
chance people see how funny he is I
remember I saw a small little clip of
his I want to go buy his tickets
immediately so I'm sold out killed it
smashed it everybody's crying [__]
laughing I every every comedy uh show
that he's done uh I mean there later on
they were bigger cuz because my buddy
bought me uh tickets to his show yeah
dude I walked out crying laughing that's
how [__] funny he was yeah it may not
translate well on the Netflix specials
but when you see him perform live dude
my [__] side you're talking about
when Kevin Hart was still hungry right
like he was still up and coming is
you're saying when you saw him right and
that Kevin Hart was a lot more funny
than current Kevin Hart not to say that
he's not funny now but but those that I
saw in that that eventually went to
Netflix it wasn't funny on Netflix to me
you have to be there he's a very
physical comedian that doesn't transl oh
I see I see so you're saying like even
if it's not funny in the Netflix version
live of of that same thing was much
better if you watch him live there's no
way you're not laughing he's so [__]
funny yeah yeah did you see how Kevin
Hart's ex-wife is on tour with Cat
Williams now really yeah as a comic
that's funny so the story is that before
before the divorce his wife was helping
him write his material and then after
the divorce it's like the people are
saying later Kevin Hart's not as
funny she's on tour with Cat Williams
get the [__] out of here and that's the
thing after that interview by the way
it's been 2 weeks 52 million views
that's [__] crazy for a three and a
half hour that was Joe Rogan Elon Musk
numbers you know that's [__] crazy so
good for Club sh Shay that's the new I
guess that's the black ran now no he
said he he said hey we're going to take
this to another Stratosphere like you're
going to another place after this yeah
like now I know I bet there's a-listers
who want to get on Club sh oh yeah oh
100% he totally changed the face of what
that show is yeah no everybody's been
milking whatever they can from the the
Ripple effects of of that uh podcast for
sure there's this clip of during the
first time he came out and he was going
at Kevin Hart where he was talking to
camera he was like I'll put up $1
million you put up a million we'll do
whatever you want basketball [__] run
track or what I was like cat relax bro
you gonna break your [__] legs Kevin
Hart would smoke this morning yeah yeah
Kevin Hart's on HGH dude Kevin Hart is
fit and also that boy can ball dude I
was like Kevin Hart would smash him to
pieces I don't know why people just look
over this part they go like like that's
important Cat Williams got beat up
everyone keeps saying seventh grader
right no he's he was seven the kid's
like seven like 17 yeah but he's a big
kid though let's be fair let's be fair
right um but yeah some of the outlandish
things that he said like you keep saying
you cannot Overlook come on Prince
coming to him for advice on cars wom CL
and fashion in what
world is Prince coming to you for
[__] advice on women and fashion bro
like no Purple Rain I
that
I wrote that yeah after I had the
prowler on Friday he Prince got the
prowler no no no no sir no no
no the funniest [__] that had me [__]
rolling was when talking about Cedric
and he said you had him looking here
like a walrus and you didn't say nothing
with his short
arm and then and then he said he would
have got up and punched him in the he
actually stood up and did the
motion that guy was so crazy what it's
it's hard for me to believe him when he
says I have never been on meth yeah come
on guys it's hard for me to believe that
cuz I seen it up close he also does a
very good job of using his example of
him adopting children as to like
highlight him as this amazing human
being right and a lot of people focus on
that like I said all these things are
valid but you have to look at the bigger
picture out of everything he said half
of it was [__] half of it I believe
yeah you know say absolutely it sounds
like a crazy person it legit sounds like
a [__] person that's insane that
knows a little something that that that
knee rubbing thing there's another video
from the 1930 something Olympics in Nazi
Germany Hitler Hitler doing he's on me
he's
on yeah he's definitely on some [__] and
he could deny this also too it's like
when he brings up like he also said on
an interview that he he goes I'm the I'm
the standup comic a lot I think he was
on uh bre club and he said he's a stand
up with the most amount of specials out
there which isn't true I think it's
actually Russell Peters proba Russell
pet cuz Russell Peters doesn't do
anything but standup yeah he doesn't do
films movies nothing I think he had a
small stim with a TV show and he had a
terrible experience that he stopped
doing that a small roll on source code
he was a standup comedian yeah so he
says like he's the one with the most
standup specials out of everybody which
isn't true once again and then people
will fact check it but they'll just
[__] glaze over it I'm like that's
important that speaks to his character
as a person for sure
which is so [__] odd dude he when he
called out Steve Harvey he was like he
was like he said that he gave up stand
up because of all the TV shows the seven
shows or whatever yeah he goes well you
gave us stand up before those seven
shows you gave up because you tried to
go toe to- Toe with me and I [__]
expose you for your Baldhead did you see
that Detroit clip no I never saw the
first time I heard of it so I youtubed
it it's there he goes in on Steve Harvey
he just on stage on stage yeah wow so it
that part that story was true the
championship of Comedy it was a real
thing that apparently Steve Harvey went
in didn't take it seriously and then Cat
Williams comes up next and just [__]
destroys him and he says that's when you
quit comedy and I believe that yeah
that's what I'm saying a lot of his
stuff it seems real the other stuff I'm
not so sure about there was the Ali
sadik story that happened afterwards did
you see that so Ali sadik commented on
the club Shay Instagram yeah like he's
[__] heated and the next thing he
post is him training for boxing like he
wants to beat the [__] out of Cat
Williams all think if you guys don't
know he's a stand up comic he went to
jail was like a Harden criminal or some
[__] like that so um he told a story on
another podcast of basically he and cat
went to a big venue together like an
arena where Ali sadik was supposed to
perform as well he claims that the
security guards linked arm and arm and
blocked him from going in right and then
he said cat wouldn't come out to help
him and get him and then he said some
one of his ladies handed him a check for
like some thousands of dollars you know
and they were like there's your money
but he didn't get to perform so since
then he's been crazy pissed so Cat
Williams had another interview on that
same podcast where Ali sadique told that
story and he was like I'm on tour I have
my own comics on my tour I was in your
city and you just thought you could just
be on my show yeah I paid you to go
away so he wasn't even on the bill then
yeah that's what cat Willi was saying
you weren't on the bill it was my tour
with the the other Comics touring with
me yeah that's so F that seems a pretty
realistic yeah I mean at the end of the
day you got your money right that that
was part of the thing of cat's
generosity like I'm sorry this you
thought that and you paid him money yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's so F you know the
thing too it's I looked up his net worth
and it's true they say like his net
worth is only like a few M I'm like
there's no [__] way dude like this
guy's books and sell [__] out like that
he also has Netflix deals whatever
there's no [__] way he's worth that
little money and all the standup he had
in the 2000s all DVD yeah and he owns it
yeah each piece of those sales but those
net worth things are never accurate
there's no way it's so off for him
though I'm like he owns all of his
specials yeah and literally Pimp
Chronicles is probably one of the most
like viewed or bought special of all
time like I mean I might be exaggerating
but it's up there though you know what I
mean [__] was one of the funniest ones
at the time was so [__] funny
probably still funny till this day right
so I'm I'm kind of like shocked about
that type of stuff so this is where
everybody gets confused about what's
real and what's not cuz I'm as I'm
listening to it I'm like [__] and
say something else I'm like that's seems
pretty real right or or that was just
funny you know yeah yeah I think the the
thing that people need to take away from
that interview that podcast is that you
got to take it with a grain of salt not
everything's facts yes he was dropping
some facts which are verifiable with
receipts but also understand there's
embellishment there's joking you know
it's all kind of mixed in so like it's
hard to kind of isolate each thing and
be like yeah that's fact that's not that
was embellished it's just like you know
just treat it as entertainment when P
Diddy wants the party you got to say no
got to protect that hole you got that
like when he was talking about like all
these meetings too saying that every
script that those people did it all came
to him first like maybe like I I don't
really know that can't I don't know if
that could be verified as true or not
but then like it was interesting how he
talks
about and I'm curious about this what
other people think too it's it's like
the idea of Hollywood like emasculating
black actors by putting them in dresses
which has been like a a topic for quite
a while right started with like Eddie
Murphy and every uh Martin Lawrence and
all this other stuff because he talked
about uh the script that was brought up
to him where Martin Lawrence was like
hey once I'm done with this stuff I want
to do a movie with you and it was big
mom too put him into a dress he goes we
don't need to be in a [__] dress you
already did that on big mom you could
dress up as something else why do you
have to be a a woman again yeah right
which is kind of an interesting topic
too because when I look at it too I I I
look at it as I think that crossdressing
thing has always been a funny Trope and
it can be really funny yeah right if it
becomes like your identity where that's
all you're doing to get a laugh that is
kind of like okay this is [__] weird
you know what I mean shout outs to all
my uh Asian Tik Tok creators where all
you do is dress up as your mom you guys
doing a great job dude yeah but it's
like no matter what you're not going to
be able to like verify that right if
there is some sort of conspiracy there
and that is true on some level I mean
also look at it like is it only black
comedians who are getting these dresses
are Asian comedians white comedians ET
for me the conspiracy with Asian
comedians is make fun of your parents
yeah right in a way that um that the
general audience will love right so one
of our friends uh was on The Voice right
she got there and then she made it to
the the production rounds where she's on
TV
but they want to do the interview and so
they want to know your your story right
and she said the producers kept telling
her to hey can you imitate your mom hey
can you do your mom's accent G right and
she was like No And then she didn't go
forward right hey it makes sense too
like they they like that [__] and I
always say this too man like you guys
see all this like Asian content and all
this other [__] and then you want
all of us to say that we like it what if
I hate it and what if it's just bad
genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by cook Unity oo if
you've got that culinary taste inside
you you know how expensive it'd be
exploring that new food scene cook Unity
is the first chef to you service
delivering locally sourced meals from
award winning shfs ride to your door
next week and every week my friends it's
cheaper than other delivery options my
friends cook Unity is the shiznet no
cooking required for a chef quality
dining experience right at your home and
let me tell you something I'm not good
at cooking fish but that delicious fish
meal that I got with that delicious
glaze on top of it was Bueno my friends
Macho which means delicious in Korean
fantastic and let me tell you something
there are times look I know I can cook
but look I ain't trying to do all this
stuff all the time by myself and if I
can get Chef cooked meals right to me
I'm going to use cook Unity baby it is
awesome your food or rice fresh never
Frozen and packaging that keeps meals
fresh in the fridge for up to 7 days and
cook unity's packaging is compostable
recyclable and reusable so experience
chef quality meals every week delivered
right to your door go to cook unity.com
genius or enter code genius before
checkout for 50% off your first week
that's 50% off your first week by using
Code genius or going to cook unity.com
genius yeah like what it's not
necessarily you not supporting your
people it's just
objectively bad yeah why can't I say
it's bad like you know it's bad too you
don't have to like something because you
feel like the social pressure of like
uplifting your people I don't want to
uplift [__] brother son I don't want
to do
it yeah yeah just because it's some
Asian [__] yeah we got to support it
like we already had that smoke with
shangi and if you want to tell us
brother's son is like the next best
thing on Netflix like [__] you honestly
[__] you yeah our friends are on it and
that's why I will never do a full review
on it because look I'm not a heartless
human being I saw a lot of familiar faes
that are really good actors or whatever
but that's not a reflection upon them
but let me tell you something I know
garbage when I see garbage and that show
is [__] garbage it is one of the
worst series I've ever seen on Netflix
next to the one that Ard and Cho did the
the loyal one that one was [__]
terrible just cuz it's Asian doesn't
mean it's good no comment from my cuz I
haven't watched the shows that you guys
are talking you should watch it if you
like Terrible Things why would I want to
watch it after I I hear we can circle
jerk our anger Dude that [__] lawyer
one too was so [__] bad it was one of
the wor it I can't even there's a
laundry list of reasons why it was so
[__] terrible that I can't even get
into it cuz what's the point right so
the flavor of what the brother's son is
too I I I I looked up IMDb who created
this it was the guy who created Glee
Jesus Christ that makes sense yeah and
now this guy wants to do a [__] show
about a comedic show about the Triads
where you glorify their violence and all
this [__] and it's like it's so weird in
tone because there's extreme violence in
it but they have these corny ass [__]
Asian jokes that make me want to throw
up yeah it's some of the worst writing
I've ever seen in my life dude terrible
terrible garbage trash writing it is a
bad show you do not have to like
something just because it's [__]
Asian and when you do that [__] by the
way too this sets a tone for what for
like what they're going to make in the
future yeah like they go oh like people
like this well continue to give this guy
more money to make [__] hot garbage
let's go get another non-asian guy to
make another Asian show which by the way
too like sgv gang [__] is very [__]
nuanced like there's plenty of source
material you can grab from aside from
this guy who did Glee yeah like come on
and even if you grab if he specifically
grabs Source material it's not something
you live through or you even understand
it's very very [__] hard right there
was a clip of Denzel talking about this
where where somebody was interviewing
him like well do you feel
like something along the lines of like
black people should are the only ones
that can make black films and he kind of
explained himself he was like well do
you know the smell of a hot comb on hair
do you like there's cultural things that
you'll never understand and this is why
it's important for people who are in the
culture to make this stuff because you
can't communicate the stuff of stuff
that you haven't lived yeah and this is
essentially like brother son it feels
like that it feels so out of place it
doesn't make sense and like the sgv
gangs aren't anything like that in the
show can you imagine like a [__]
Mafia movie like perpetuating their
stereotypes like Kung Fu how many how
many [__] SUV gangsters do kung fu
everyone's [__] fighting Kung Fu are
you serious yeah wow it's ridiculous
like that that's how they depict like
Asian gangsters yeah in they they
fighting the club doing Kung Fu do you
know what they do they shoot and stab
people yeah that's about it yeah that's
that's how that's how the sgv gangs role
not not they slice their heads off they
slice their limbs off like do they also
have n nunchucks around their neck dud
my [__] Uncle wasn't there dude it's
literally terrible right and the same
thing with that with that there was this
other CW show called Kung Fu right right
I watched two episodes of it I've never
laughed so hard in my life of how
terrible the show was right so I never
even heard of this [__] well it got
renewed for I think up to like three
seasons waste of [__] money it was
just so bad and sometimes a part of me
thinks like is there somebody that just
wants Asian people to look bad on
purpose why do you do this this is so
[__] bad because of the Chinese
market the Chinese immigrants are not
like the biggest immigrants in America
but the thing is though like even even
if it's catered or or like you know
directed at that demo like how are they
looking at that thinking oh this is
entertaining all right you know what I
mean I don't know because it's Asian
[__] oh that's that's me that's my
family really your mom cut up dead
bodies yeah you know like I I it's just
hard to swallow you know what sucks too
like when I saw brother son so I
auditioned for brothers son for a role
in there right the the what I read in
the script did not translate to what I
saw in that show and I think that's what
irritated me the most it's like what the
[__] this was not what it was told like
when I read the script originally I was
like this is so [__] weird so I'm a
world that I definitely wouldn't have
gotten cuz I saw the character I was
like wait this was like [__] like 18
years old how the [__] would I play like
an 18-year-old makes no sense I got like
callbacks for it too I don't know what
was going on there I don't know how that
[__] casting thing works well
blessing in disguise really it [__]
was though then you would have to
promote it and internally you're like
dying inside well this is like my
biggest fear too let's say one day I
decide to go you know write another film
right and then my film's terrible I have
to review my own film yeah like this
[__] was [__] bad
dude terrible choices but it's like like
I'm not saying that you know oh could
you could you do better actually I think
I could but I honestly think I could but
watching things like that it just
doesn't make me feel good either like
I'm not going to go into main reason why
I'm not going to do a full review that
means I have to watch every episode and
I can't do it I I'll literally die I'll
do the most Asian thing and I'll [__]
sepu myself right now I'll [__] stab
myself in the [__] gut I won't do it
it's so bad I just need to say what
pissed me off the most was in the first
episode this guy kills a [__] in
his mom's house and his mom comes home
and then they have to clean up the dead
body and it's and he says it's not safe
here right we got to go but then they
spend the night for the next two
days I'm like who who's thinking like
then you're a [__] idiot how are you
the leader of these these this gang [__]
doesn't make sense it's crazy yeah I
don't man I don't I don't like I said a
lot of our friends were in their
familiar faces really cool you guys all
got duped like that that was not it that
[__] was not [__] hopefully they got
some Netflix money out of it then no I'm
good I'm glad friends are getting paid
I'm glad that they're making money but
like I'm not going to be on that side of
just like saying things are good just
for the sake of it cuz we've definitely
celebrated a lot of great stuff that
we're you know Asian Asian-American that
was [__] amazing yeah everything
everywhere all at once right it's not
cuz we're hating on Chinese [__] like
everything everywhere all at once is the
dop [__] you don't like a shangi you
don't like a Muran and now you don't
like a brother son
action doesn't help huh I read those in
the comments man they were saying oh
it's cuz they're Korean they don't like
Chinese [__] it's like well maybe you
shouldn't have given us Co then huh boom
boom roasted yeah Trump uh
2024 I just want to piss people off oh
my God no I'm just kidding I'm kidding
but like well like there there's [__]
going on in our country too yeah that
that we're not proud of oh yeah yeah
let's segue into that right I mean
that's yeah let's [__] on some Korean
people for a second on the entire
[__] society honestly it's the
society that d drove this man society
and culture there you know so if you
guys watched uh one of the best series
ever of course it was Korean and not
Chinese I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding movie parasite parasite amazing
one of the lead actor
eong right orun Eun right so we've seen
this guy act forever I've seen him in
everything he was actually in one of my
no I think you haven't get mixed up he
played the father of the man the big
house oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's one of
the main characters right so eong Yun
like I actually saw him not for the
first time but I've seen him in many
things over the years right and so for a
lot of people their first introduction
was parasite well he's been in this
industry for a very [__] long time
and he was actually in a Korean drama
that I really liked with uh it was
called my mister oh yeah with IU with IU
that was such a good series it was
really slow paced it was shot really
well which isn't very typical of a lot
of Korean dramas usually Korean drama
why people like them because everything
is so unrealistic it's like an enjoyable
watch for a lot of people the reason why
I don't like it but that's why a lot of
Korean people like kramas because it's
not realistic and it's out of this
[__] world right um he ends up
killing himself in his car now this
becomes like a whole [__] thing this
happened like a month about a month ago
and what I was watching this I know a
lot of people wanted us to talk about
this real quick but I wanted things to
kind of unfold for a little bit you had
to especially like cuz right off the bat
the next day like situation was
unfolding with like blackmailers and all
this [__] right things just didn't
really make sense right uh I was talking
to a friend in Korea and then she was
kind of giving me like a Down Low of
what people in Korea think is happening
right so drugs in Korea are highly
forbidden like you you smoke weed you're
in jail for like life it's it's it's
like one of those things kacho means
devil smoke right yeah yeah so the
current president of Korea is cracking
down on drug use like going crazy on it
and what what's one of the best ways to
do that is to find somebody to a martyr
to find somebody to pin it on yeah right
and they've been doing that with
celebrities G Dragon would be one of
them yeah he got involved in this case
with yeah so apparently the place that
quote unquote where they were doing
drugs or some illegal activities is
where a lot of politicians go to a lot
of celebrities go to VIP brothel pretty
much VIP brothel right and it's like
kind of known for that type of stuff so
there is like speculation just from like
Korean people talking from what I've
heard from my friend in Korea she said
that a lot of people think that it's
just it's more than just what's being
shown here right oh I'm sure I'm sure
yeah like even outside influence mhm um
we're going to get into what was kind of
released later on with the whole
blackmailing thing but she was telling
me was like people are starting to
suspect that you know there's more than
just uh the police involved it's like
probably Mafia type of [__] too because
he was caught there and then he could
release information so they're thinking
that's like other [__] like that too
that's happening that's what people in
Korea are thinking too um but later on
as you guys find out that this guy was
being [__] blackmailed by a a a
Korean actress yeah I I forget what her
name is but she was in Kim sojong yeah
Kim sojong she was like in train the pan
or something she was like in a lot of
things but she's in fellow actress that
kind of former actress that fell out she
ended up like in prison for that just
that kind of [__] so she where she met
the other black mailer as well yeah she
had a roommate I guess yeah a cellmate
yeah like a Korean drama yeah yeah no
this is like a [__] drama for sure
like the how deep this Rabbit Hole went
and then so like yeah they they these
two blackmailers right um met in prison
and then uh one of them said that she
got her phone hacked and there was
information about uh eong Yun on there
about his drug use about you know him
visiting the brothel and that this
hacker hacker is is threatening to
release this information unless you pay
x amount of money right and she was
recording their phone calls right right
and then so it's like the rans it's it's
a ransom it's a ransom situation right
basically saying yeah you got to pay the
ransom otherwise this guy's going to you
know release this [__] it was like an
equivalent of like
$350,000 something like that that's a
ridiculous number 35 million one which
is yeah 350,000 like something I forgot
what it was but it was really [__]
high but like the whole thing that just
kind of was interesting was that she's
she's so good at this she's done this to
like Five Guys simultaneously with one
[__] kid she convinced like five
dudes that it was theirs yeah until one
guy apparently was smart enough to get a
paternity that he somehow got it and
then she went through a court case cuz
he was suing the [__] [__] out of her
cuz he was paid for child support for
this kid that wasn't his which is
[__] ins how good is this girl's
[__] like [__] crazy she like a
Venus fly bow bowow all these
[__] dude how yeah I mean it's
pretty easy if you think about it
because it's a very exclusive brothel
cuz like apparently you know minimum
spend is like $7,500 a night or some
[__] right and so you know people of
like certain wealth and Status are going
to frequent these places which is a
small circle and then within that you're
going to have you know x amount of
madams right who are there and so it's
not $500 a lot yeah so it's not that
hard to get into these little situations
with these celebrities or politicians
whatever and then once you got them by
the balls literally and figuratively you
you exploit that you know you milk that
[__] there's like this weird thing that
happens in Korea where your public
perception is so [__] important right
and so when he went through this whole
thing he was like oh you could drug test
me whatever what now it turns out that
he didn't have any drugs in his system
so he didn't do any drugs ask for a
light test well guess what like the
president of Korea is very serious about
drugs so they started doing more [__] oh
it turns out he has a mistress he has
all this other stuff so they kept
digging further and further and further
to use him as an example yeah that you
shouldn't do [__] drugs even though
he didn't do it and they basically
ruined his [__] life yeah well the
thing is it's it's you know up in the
air of whether or not he did drug he
didn't do drugs close to the time of
when he got tested now did he do it in
the past maybe no yeah maybe they do
[__] like hair sample testing so the
other girl with the kid she also
blackmailed the girl who's blackmailing
soj exactly she [__] stole one of her
hair strands I know you do drugs so you
need to get me this much this much
amount of money or whoever yeah or I'm
going to give your a hair sample to the
police so the black mailer got that's
how serious they are about [__] drugs
then they look if you did drugs in the
past 8 months or to a year if you did
drugs at any point in that time even
though it's not in your system now then
you go to jail for you get prosecuted
for that [__] so that's how it all
started unraveling cuz this this [__]
got caught up and then so now she's like
ratting on pretty much everybody just
kill this girl yeah so she terrible
person she doesn't yeah she she should
be away so you know the the blackmailer
who blackmailed the blackmailer I mean
we'll say a and b right B the second
black mailer ended up getting money as
well but then it was it wasn't that much
it was like 40 40 Grand yeah for like 40
Grand or something so both of them got
money out of this situation but even
still [__] hit the fan and unfortunately
it was uh yeah eong Yun and G Dragon who
got caught up in the fire now G Dragon
has had his mishaps with the law in the
pass with drug use marijuana in Japan or
something I mean he's a musician of but
but no no but here here's the thing
here's the thing like this is such a a
reflection of like Korean culture and
society and and how it's perceived
outside and within Korea they want to
maintain this pristine oh I'm a family
man or I'm a family woman I'm I'm a I'm
this you know uh like innocent K-pop
Star these are still human beings guys
you know what I mean you can't hold them
to like like these K-pop men men they're
not [__] monks they're men with needs
just like every other man just like
every other woman let me tell you
something how stupid [__] K-pop I'm
start with my wife all
right I love her very much right we got
into our our last biggest fight was like
while ago but I was talking you know cuz
we know people in K-pop right and we
know like inside stories and stuff and
she loves BTS yeah she oh my God these
guys are such good people I was like you
don't know them they are not friends
exactly right she goes what do you know
I was like dude we've literally gone
through this right so for example there
was these two musicians that she
idolized right turns out they all
cheated on their [__] significant
others right had kids with other people
she was like so shocked I'm like that's
your [__] problem that's a standard
though yeah it's like you idolize these
people you don't [__] know them
that's like it's like a given in Korea
with with a lot of these people like
that's what they do behind the yes in in
in the front-facing um stuff like these
agencies will say oh these Idols cannot
date they cannot do certain what you
think they're doing behind exact I saw
first I'm not going to name drop any
people but I'm talking about some big
[__] names when they're in La they're
partying they're drinking they're doing
drugs and they want to [__] hey and
these are the makeup boys yeah I'm not
hating on them I'm I'm not hitting on
them I'm saying that's what they are
yeah you look at their makeup their
madeup image and and you think that's
what it is it's not that dude there was
this uh very popular group back in the
time back in the day right where I
remember it was like the show that they
wanted me to MC for right met this guy
seemingly nice dude scumbag though
absolute [__] scumbag right but once
again you see them on these like these
pel like these shows and they're just so
pristin they talk about how neat and
clean they are how how much they love
their fans this dude sexually harassing
the [__] out of these girls right right
to the point where they felt
uncomfortable and then uh one of the
people had to pull him aside like hey
you got to chill the [__] out he's like
giving attitude cuz he's so drunk out of
his mind he's snap grabbing These Girls
by the arms we had to like stop and like
hey you can't [__] touch people like
that but it's like you don't want to
hear these type of things this is who
not everybody's going to be good yeah
there might be some great people no for
sure man but but here's the [__] up
part is that when it comes to light now
oh now you're going to get [__]
lynched you're going to get [__]
lynched by the public the same public
who's accepting of this [__] even part
in it but because they need to maintain
that front-facing image oh that's not
who we are as a people as a culture as a
society we're good you know family
people we would never do something and
and how dare this [__] you know
Heathen cheat on his wife and do drugs
like this this guy and then they'll sign
netizens will go crazy with it hundreds
of thousands of people will sign a
petition kill yourself yeah kill your
like that's not a joke they yeah they'll
they'll do that and they'll sign it
remember uh so there's a popular boy
group at the time called hot they're
like one of the ogs right so hot it was
uh genius brain farts well this podcast
is brought to you by fume listen cold
turkey may be great on sandwiches but
there's a better way to break your bad
habits and listen we're not talking
about that mind voodo from your crazy
neighbor we're talking about our sponsor
fume baby and they look at the problem
in a different way not everything in a
bad habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habit see
fume is an Innovative award-winning
flavored air device that does just that
I keep mine in my car I puff away at it
it tastes really good because guess what
it's awesome it's more flavorable than I
thought and it feels very fresh and if
you're wondering what it tastes like you
just have to think of like refreshing
herbal tea and guess what that's what
you get all natural baby the weight on
it feels great so if you're fidgety in
your car you could use it all day and it
helps with somebody like me who got like
ADHD I got a fid FID all the time and
that's what I use it for I keep it in my
car all day so start the year off right
with the good habit by going to trf
nume.com genius and getting the journey
packed today fume is giving listeners of
the show 10% off when they use my code
genius to help make starting the good
habit that much easier so start the
goodh Habit at
trium.vira [__] death threats yeah to
both of them telling they'll [__]
kill them they'll kill themselves if
they don't break up how could you like
as if they were together with them like
you you we own you how could you do this
that I mean it's like you [__] Mania
you [__] losers but but that comes
with the territory CU that's how they
package it you know what I mean that's
how it's also they have to take
responsibility for that they're the one
who they perpetuate that [__] right and
and so like you know you got to
understand people need to understand
fans of K-pop fans of kdrama fans of
these celebrities actors entertainers
whatever understand that they're still
human beings at the end of the day you
know and and they're going to do things
that other humans do despite how much
they want to show you that that's not
who they are or they would never do
something like that no that is not the I
mean look at [__] Sun from big bang
right this was sex he was a [__]
scumbag to the max you if anybody Saw
His Image prior to that would they ever
think he did something no that's
packaged but then there's flip side to
this guy like Kingo who was a [__]
Legend if you guys don't know who he is
he was a a pop singer in in K-pop I mean
not K-pop but like oh yeah K-pop I guess
who was one of like the pioneers of of
K-pop legend by side with sa right right
and and he and you
know he he was hugely popular in his
Heyday uh kind of had like a break in
his career and then had like a
Resurgence doing variety shows but then
allegations came of sexual assault
turned out not true but at that point
the damage was done the public turned
everybody turned on them he got booted
off all the shows it's like your career
is done oh by the way he's not guilty
yeah but they don't give a [__] yeah
they don't I mean it was a public
lynching they just [__] throw them
away it's nothing they [__] drag this
guy through the mud and it's like well
all right well that's why [__]
Korea's suicide rate uh [__] just
beat Japan yeah we're the best baby
number one cor Neu
never lose like Japan kills themselves
because they like find
no you know cuz since World War II the
death of the uh image of the emperor
right so the death of God for them
essentially well as Japan like
economically grew and such a lot of
Japanese people lost their sense of self
and identity and who they are and the
the just the idea of existence like
we're just supposed to like just grow as
a country So Korea is going through that
right now but on top of that it's
because of idol culture it's because
like they create gods for them and then
they want to destroy those Gods at the
same time right it's so [__] weird
like I really think if uh isun if he was
in America this wouldn't be it would be
a
nonissue got some side [__] yeah I mean
look he might have faced some criticism
and then that it would pass and then he
goes resume I mean look at tyer Woods
right yeah he's back hey look at Kevin
Hart yeah he's back look at cat
Williams back he's back so you know it's
it's just so funny that in in a society
in a culture where so much shady [__]
goes on behind the scenes they they try
so [__] hard to maintain this
pristine image of themselves when it's
like dude all you [__] like it's so
bad that it's like an unspoken almost
agreement when somebody when a man
enters the workforce in in corporate
culture over there that they're going to
go out they're going to sleep with these
women out when when their bosses want to
go out but the wives just have to
understand that if they don't do that
they can't climb up the the ladder yeah
that's I remember that in the uh early
2010s yeah there was a movement to shut
down Korea's like red light district
right right guess who came to protest
who the wives of course the wives of
course how are our husbands going to
like you know advance in in in their
workplace if our husbands don't do that
they're going to do that [__] to us ex I
don't want to have a sex with him yeah
yeah that so Weir so bad hey like even
within family members even within family
members I've seen it present where it's
like and then and then there's like it's
just weird thing of like oh you got to
draw the line at you can't have kids
with them though like you can you can
like you know hang out with them [__]
them whatever but no kids and and like
you still got to spend good good amount
of time I saw a bunch of interviews of
like these women who say this stuff and
I think like their logic is
like they're just using them so you
could use them as much as you want like
they're just they're [__] trash or or
or it's hey I don't want to do that my
boss is making me though what do you
want me to do that can be true but it
can also be [__] I'm taking like the
the wom the wives are saying that to
like they're just using those women I
don't care but if you get intimate with
them that's something different like you
could have sex just use them because
they look at those women like here like
you're just whatever and so hypocritic
one Speaking of the red light district
right it's supposed to be illegal
prostitution supposed to be illegal it's
like a tourist attraction yeah exactly
but it's just it's just to say face it's
just to have it there on paper but but
like rangs and and brothel like dude
there's you don't even have to [__]
be from there to know where to go you
know what I mean you can get like like
these Tommy girls in K Town in Los
Angeles yeah they run the same type of
surface in K Town I remember when uh I
forgot what that place was [__]
called but they were bringing like a
couple of like Tomy girls like to the
table I didn't know what this stuff was
I'm not from La yeah you're like uh
you're in the wrong room yeah they like
come in I'm like the [__] who the [__]
are you I don't know what the [__] is
going on and I'm like yeah for for those
of you guys who are listening or
watching and don't know what tomies are
tomies are basically like escorts and uh
when you go to like karaoke which is
called nbang and Korean nrbs um there's
services and so what happens with these
Tomy Services is that like there's these
Vans these agencies quote unquote
agencies um that have these Tomy
services and you call them or or the the
the karaoke place has a relation ship
with them or a partnership with them and
then when you get into the room they'll
bring you lines of girls and basically
you pick it's like the girlfriend
experience yeah you pick which one you
want to like party with but some of them
obviously aren't just escorts they'll
also be prostitutes for another another
fee right and so this is like going on
pretty openly in K Town but like you
also kind of have to know that NTI to
know what's you know it's happening yeah
yeah yeah dude so um this guy I know you
know he's younger than me but he had a
lot of money right but he was just in
sales so I was like damn I guess you do
well and then he told me he's like
actually like he runs an agency okay you
know and that's I remember like where
I'd see him at like C and then it's just
like tens all 10 sitting by him yeah I
was like oh that's that's your life
right yeah and one day he sends me a
message right he's like hey do you know
this girl I'm like yeah that's my friend
she applied to work for me and in her
photo it was us two together what the
[__] God and she didn't know that he
knows me oh my God so funny like oh my I
mean but but here's the thing right is
that before it used to be exclusively
Korean girls and
bunch of Russian girls no because they
caught wind of like how much money you
can make from doing this type of [__]
and so regular ass girls who just happen
to be hot are willingly signing up for
this [__] because and and some of them
won't do the prostitution part they'll
just party drink and and make ton of
money that's what you're not supposed to
do you're supposed to just it's like the
girlfriend experience yeah they pour
your drinks they'll put yeah it's just
like it's supposed to be that and if
people want to do the extracurricular
they'll do the extracurricular yeah yeah
that so I didn't know about there's also
toldy boys so I met one yeah that used
to work at this Cafe that's not open
anymore yeah but this dude was just had
the nicest car I was like [__] how the
[__] you get on you [__] work here
yeah there's rangs with I think it's
called hopas or something like that I'll
tell you this though this dude fine as
[__] I'll tell you this I was like God
damn this guy's fine so I you know I
ended up talking to him asking him
questions I was likey how do I be one
first of all you're a little
ugly but I I was asking him like so
what's it like like what do you guys he
goes honestly he goes I'm not doing
anything dirty he goes I'm just hanging
out with these women these older women
mdle who are using their husband's money
cuz they know that the husband's [__]
other girls so they take the money from
their husband to be like [__] you I'm
going use your money for this type of
[__] so she doesn't say anything about
his and he knows but he's not going to
say anything he knows that she knows
they both know silently yeah it he told
me on a weekend like the weekend that I
was there getting like for a PES or
whatever having coffee or whatever he
like d this week I me 8 Grand no 8 Grand
in the weekend dude it's no joke man I
like even even some of these like uh
cougars right they'll they'll try to
pick up young I knew a cat back in the
day right he found a sugar mama in K
Town right she gave him a pager she
basically page when she wants to [__]
and give him yton which is allowance
$33,000 in cash dude I would [__] the
[__] out of you for $3,000
yeah oh my God and it was the same
situation she was a married woman uh
wealthy husband but her husband's always
on business travel okay so what are the
requirements for this job you have to
look good no it wasn't a job it wasn't a
job he went to a club where it was known
that there's cougars on the prow and and
and he just got picked up yeah he got
picked up by one of these ladies if I
ever get buffed you guys already know
what I'm doing I'm over here just
[__] bagging these old Korean ladies
with your with your turtle neck ready to
don't worry I'll make it quick I come
fast a while ago I didn't know if I
should bring this up a while ago this
girl sent me this video I I forget if it
was I think it was a short film about
Tommy Boy essentially and it was like a
story about the life of a doy boy right
and I thought she was sending it to me
to look at a piece of art but she asked
me would you consider doing this right
and I'm like
um here's the thing she's not like an
older lady or nothing yeah I thought it
was weird that she asked me if I would
be a DOI boy though dude I would be so
flattered I've never been asked that I
got I got a story for you about uh my
experience with tomies right so one time
I went out with like a company thing uh
when I was working for a Korean company
and um we go to a norang right this is
the Sacha which is in Korean it means
like the third stop right like dinner
drinks and then another like karaoke
bar I don't I know what's going to
happen right I I know what's coming and
so I'm already like kind of preparing my
exit by telling them hey I'm just GNA
stay here for about 10 minutes and I'm
going to leave I was trying not to even
go to the third spot but they're like no
you have to [__] come so okay but I'm
going to leave in like 10 minutes so the
girls start coming in all the [__]
dudes are picking girls and then the
boss man he's like edric pick a girl I'm
like no it's cool like I'm going to take
off so it's fine like I don't want you
to waste your money I'm going to leave
in 10 minutes he's like no no just pick
a girl I'm like no no I I I really don't
need to pick a girl I'm going to take
off he's like pick a girl now all right
all right that one she come sits down
next to me I lean over I whisper in her
ear it's like hey uh I'm going to take
off in like 10 minutes so don't even
worry about it like you can just leave
whenever right and shees tries to start
talking to me like she just kind of
ignores what I say and TR like no yeah
she's already in in game mode right and
I'm like [__] and then I I I sit there
for about 10 minutes these dudes are
[__] going Z to 100 right off the bat
song comes on one of them's grabbing the
girls by the titty like and they're cool
with it they're just kind of like
laughing and you know and I'm like oh
dude I need to get the [__] out of here
like this so I start walking out boss
man comes out he like Corners me he's
said hey you all right and I'm like like
yeah yeah I'm fine why he's like why why
did you not want to pick a girl I'm like
I told you cuz I was going to leave like
I'm tired I just want to go home and
then he like kind of pauses and he's
like real serious looks me dead in the
eye edric are you gay that's so [__]
funny dude that's always old Korean man
answer you don't want to do scumbag
stuff are you gay he said he said no
yeah and then goes oh if you are it's
fine I have a I have a boy and then and
then another another guy comes I come
out from the
back another guy comes out and he's like
already Tipsy hey Andrew like what's
going on man you gay or what oh my God
it's like yo one more person calls I I'm
going to fight somebody right now dude I
was like no man I don't want to [__]
do scumbag [__] like that you know I'm
like but I didn't say that I was just
like no it's not nothing like that I'm
like I'm I'm just tired I want to go
home it's just a weird thing to happen
especially if nobody gives like for me
nobody gave me a heads up they assumed
that I knew what was happening and then
you see like these and I'm like in my
mind I'm like [__] this ain't free
get the [__] out of here just a bunch of
strangers I'm like I hope you all ladies
know you're all paying for this too you
know cuz I'm like what the [__] is going
on and then as I going on I'm like oh
these women are paid to be here this is
different this is [__] weird I mean
if you don't know what you're walking
into so weird because just a line of
girls walk in and they literally just
standing in front of you and then they
just point you if if you see a Toyota
Sienna in K Town there's women in there
any minivan that's that's tinted out and
has LED lights at the bottom and and
look prostitutions agencies also exist
in ktown and what these people do is
they rent out like apartment rooms that
are just basically [__] rooms and so
nobody lives there it's just strictly a
prostitution and so like you you see
them like if you you guys know you in K
Town when you see these hot ass girls
coming out in groups they live there
they they're either doing prostitution
and or aromies if I boss forced me to
talk to one of those ladies of the night
I would say hey let's go to this room
and I would make her do math problems I
was like hey you still got to pay for
the time I was like you got to pay for
this time hey girl you got to do these
quadratic equations she'll be so [__]
mad she's like can we just have sex no
no no no no no no solve this no but the
thing is it's like it for for you know
so many people like we would be in the
minority of of not wanting to engage in
that and feeling uncomfortable in that
situation most people that's just like a
given we going out to K Town all right
call the [__] I don't like it yeah
dude it's just so it's very creepy grimy
I had one experience with a doy girl too
similar to yours where I didn't ask for
it yeah
um uh a TV guy we know you know I was at
noton with him cuz he just likes the
party and he was telling me pick one and
pick one and I was same same thing no no
dude I'm trying to sing these
songs oh so you trying to actually still
sing yeah I love [__] singing dude
but um he picks a girl right and it's
just a very bubbly Latino girl and like
yeah big
gazungas and essentially he said he's
paying for it so okay whatever you do
your J job and then what they do is they
hold the remote they hold the paper they
say what song you want to sing and then
they'll look and then they input it they
do all that [__] for you pour your
drinks and try to feed you right well
you know I'm not the one like paying for
it I'm just like going along I'm really
trying to
sing you get mad at them stop touching
me it's my song at the end of the night
this girl sits on my lap and then grabs
my hands and then just mashes her
titties uhhuh on it right yeah oh so she
was the one who does the extracurricular
yeah and then I was like what the [__]
and then she grabbed my arm and took me
out right and she was
like that's $120 oh just a cop of field
I don't know I was like oh I'm not
paying for this she was like and then
she was [__] pissed all this [__] I
was like holy what the [__] am I did I
get myself into the guy comes out and
he's drunk I was like bro you said and
he's like h and now he's not gonna pay
oh man like I was so [__] mad at this
guy for putting me in the situation I
would be pissed that $120 only got me
titty
grabs it was for the hour which I was
like Madame that is not worth it yeah
which was forced on you too it's not
even like you went for it I you didn't
even listen to my problems like you
didn't do any of that stuff he paid her
she left and I go back in the room and
now my friends are giving me dagger eyes
thinking I'm a [__] trash bag they
were like damn dude you just like
grabbed her titties and I was like
no no I was trying to sing Can You Feel
the Love Tonight you know and she said
Can You Feel these
tonight oh man I I didn't even last that
long once that started happen I just
left I was like I can't be around this
[__] cuz I well you know for me it's
just uncomfortable like I just well it's
uncomfortable and like you know back in
the days there before it became like
really glamorized and and girl started
doing will I mean some of them were
trafficked you know and so like that
idea did not sit well with me I don't
even care if they're not trafficed like
I I don't [__] believe in paying for
any type of [__] like that and that's
why your B thought you were gay D he
[__] stared at me he said no gay well
guys this is where we're going to end
the
podcast don't get caught upat Shady sh
genius brain at 12:00 p.m. every Sunday
secret society SE R TS o c IE Ty y.com
and plug your podcast uh Bible Study
Bible
study me
girl don't do it it's not very good you
guys are all going to go to hell you
could be like me just go at the look at
these women and say hey I'm not paying
for any of this [__] and then you find
out that they do illegal stuff and you
just walk out easy [__] and then you get
criticized for being gay yep so just
take that criticism we'll see you all
next time peace peace